ce sont les bureaux de la présidence
mais depuis le début de la guerre c'est
aussi chez lui voilà des meilleurs
Zelinski ne quitte presque jamais cet
endroit où il nous reçoit pour sa toute
première entrevue avec des médias
canadiens
tout au cours de l'entretien d'une heure
le président de l'estra jamais
complètement son téléphone à chaque
tentative de frappe aérienne il est
prévenu
un moment s'excuse alors qu'une nouvelle
frappe est déjouée par le système de
défense aérien déployée autour de Kiev
de plus en plus ce sont les drones qui
sont source d'angoisse et de destruction
des engins kamikazes à la technologie
rudimentaire et fabriquée par l'Iran
avoir fourni ces drones à la Russie et à
offerte d'engager un dialogue avec Kiev
pour dissiper les allégations voilà
catégorique l'Iran man soutenir
des centaines de frappes sur l'Ukraine
sur la capitale sur les infrastructures
civiles des écoles près d'université à
l'université et la destruction de notre
système énergétique pour que les gens ne
survivent pas à l'hiver il tue les gens
soit par la fin en bloquant les voies
maritimes soit par le froid en gelant
c'est ce qu'il faut maintenant de quel
type de confiance parlons-nous
l'armée de la ukrainienne affirme
aujourd'hui avoir détruit 223 de ses
grandes chahead 136 depuis la
mi-septembre
je veux le souligner je ne parle pas
citoyens de la société peuvent subir un
lavage de cerveau comme la Russie fait
ils peuvent dire à leurs citoyens qui ne
vendent rien mais c'est un mensonge un
mensonge parfait il tue notre peuple
la diplomatie européenne abonde dans le
même sens et affirme avoir suffisamment
de preuves qui démontrent que les drones
n'utilisés par la Russie ont été fournis
par l'Iran elle promettent une réponse
européenne claire rapide et ferme
une réponse ferme et rapide le président
zellenski l'attendent aussi de la
communauté internationale sur la menace
nucléaire le président ukrainien
voudrait que l'on exige par tous les
moyens que la Russie se retire
entièrement ses soldats émersionnels
compris de la centrale nucléaire des
aporisiens
ça doit être une exigence du monde
entier de l'aïe de l'Europe demain
immédiatement quitter la centrale
autrement l'agence atomique devrait
rompre toute relation avec la Russie
l'exclure de l'organisation il faut des
gestes puissants pas seulement un
dialogue
nous n'avons pas à répondre à toutes
sortes de conditions qui peuvent imposer
il faut montrer que le monde est plus
fort qu'un terroriste et vous le
terroriste aller obéir à nous demande
pour que l'on considère même s’asseoir
et négocié avec vous aussi
accusait l'Ukraine et son président
d'être responsable de l'explosion du
pont de Crimée une infrastructure
importante pour le territoire annexé
illégalement par la Russie en 2014 et
hautement symbolique pour le président
russe Vladimir Poutine vous a accusé
accusé l'Ukraine vous personnellement
d'avoir ordonner l'explosion sur le pont
de Crimée qui est survenue environ deux
semaines est-ce que vous vos services de
sécurité en ont donné l'ordre
nous n'avons pas commandé pour autant
que je sache ils ont un ennemi intérieur
les problèmes des relations entre leurs
militaires et leur service spéciaux leur
service de renseignement sont très
graves aujourd'hui
vous pourriez revenir à une table de
négociation et discuter de paix avec
Vladimir Poutine
quel est l'intérêt pour moi le président
d'un État indépendant de parler avec une
personne qui dit quelque chose et qui
change d'opinion le lendemain les
référendums ont marqué un point final de
Norauto ils doivent d'abord nous rendre
notre territoire silver négocier
vraiment que ce soit sur une possible
adhésion à l'OTAN ou sur le soutien au
peuple ukrainien et à son effort de
guerre voilà des meilleurs Zelinski n'a
que de bons mots à l'égard du Canada et
de son premier ministre Justin Trudeau
le Canada n'a pas accédé à toutes les
demandes d'armes de l'Ukraine mais les
deux pays entretiennent des liens
étroits ancrés dans une histoire et des
valeurs communes si le Président
nous ne demandons même pas comment
diplomatiquement le Canada peut nous
soutenir parce que nous sommes sûrs que
c'est un soutien une assurance blindée
je suis très reconnaissant de ce soutien
c'est plus qu'un partenariat c'est plus
grand que ça c'est plutôt comme être une
famille
remercier ses alliés tout en exerçant
juste assez de pression pour conserver
voir augmenter leur soutien pour une
guerre qui mène sans relâche depuis des
mois est un travail de tous les instants
pour tout comme celui de préserver le
moral et la motivation de son peuple à
combattre il se montre particulièrement
habile dans ce rôle de président en
temps de guerre un dirigeant inspirant
il lui faut parfois trouver l'énergie
dit-il et surtout ne jamais s'habituer à
la guerre
moi je danse
de quelque chose
vous pouvez vous habituer à la guerre et
vous habituer au nombre de victimes vous
pouvez vous habituer émotionnellement
mais moi je vis avec l'idée que je ne
suis pas prêt à m'habituer à notre
souffrance
à m'habituer à la guerre je refuse de
m'habituer à ce que ça ne fasse plus mal
ces meurtres
[Musique]
pour lesquels le président ukrainien se
dit convaincu que Vladimir Poutine devra
payer
la paix ne suffit pas les gens doivent
être responsables de leurs actes pour
cette situation pour cette guerre il est
nécessaire que ceux qui leur
déclenchaient soit responsable
souvenez-vous rose